mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour le titre de ce thé mission de
13h d'abord les réactions plan social
présenté hier après-midi vous savez
monsieur messmer monsieur de guerre fort
le voyage du premier ministre en alsace
qui a commencé ce matin entreront notre
envoyé spécial jacques idier en sport
une journée de championnat de football
hier soir avec une belle performance ou
le verrait de la part de l'équipe de
nice et puis à munich les épreuves
sportives ont repris et la france a
obtenu une médaille d'argent en escrime
talent parlais tout à l'heure avec
michel drucker
évidemment depuis la reprise des jeux
l'atmosphère est bien différente chacun
des athlètes ce matin à munich ne peut
oublier bien sûr les 17 morts de l'autre
nuit et la cérémonie grandiose et
dramatique hier matin dans le stade
olympique d'autant que l'on continue à
se poser des questions dans un cas
semblable est il normal que certaines
personnes remettent en cause les
normales plutôt que certaines personnes
remettent en cause les méthodes
employées pour essayer de libérer les
otages les autorités allemandes pourtant
fait semble-t-il tout ce qu'elles ont pu
pour éviter ce massage ont concocté en
continue cependant de se demander
pourquoi les fedayin ont réussi à
pénétrer dans le village olympique avec
tant de facilité
et pendant ce temps là les trois
palestiniens survivants sont interrogés
et 15 suspects arabes sont recherchés en
allemand autre chose
à noter aujourd'hui à ce propos l'équipe
olympique de l'allemagne de l'est a reçu
plusieurs lettres et plusieurs coups de
téléphone les menaçant de mort et
d'attentât à la bombe ce matin
en tout cas tous les membres de l'équipe
israélienne ont quitté munich les
cercueils des victimes également vous
allez le voir ont été rapatriés l'équipe
olympique israélienne et ses dirigeants
ont quitté munich ce matin vers 8 heures
les formalités de départ se sont
effectués à l'aéroport de vienne qui
était sévèrement gardée par la police et
les gardes-frontières pour des raisons
de sécurité jusqu'au dernier moment
l'heure du départ a été tenue secrète
les membres survivants de la délégation
israélienne ont gagné directement la
passerelle d'embarquement à bord
d'autocars si des mesures de sécurité
étaient importantes aux abords du boeing
spécial de la compagnie el al la
situation était normale sur le reste de
l'aéroport monsieur balle torche il le
ministre ouest allemand des affaires
étrangères ainsi que monsieur vos
gueules ancien maire de munich et benno
rim ambassadeurs d'israël
république fédérale ont salué les
membres de l'équipe avant que ceux ci ne
se réunissent pour une brève prière
collective
les cercueils des victimes ont été
chargées dès l'aube à bord de l'avion
qui a atterri vers 11h35 sur l'aéroport
de lod tel-aviv madame golda meilleur et
de nombreuses personnalités l'attendait
les funérailles nationales vont être
organisées aujourd'hui en israël
je ne reviens pas sur les réactions à
travers le monde qui ont été nombreuses
au cours de la journée d'hier dont nous
avons d'ailleurs longuement parlé en
israël il ya eu d'importantes
manifestations en signe de deuil et de
protestation contre le massacre de
munich
même chose en allemagne où des milliers
de personnes ont défilé hier non
seulement d'ailleurs dans la capitale
olympique munich mais encore à
düsseldorf et à berlin jacques séguin
notre envoyé spécial a été témoin de
cette journée de colère le président de
la république allemande est connu pour
sa pondération pondération vers laquelle
le pouce sont pas purement naturel et
aussi par la place que lui assigne la
constitution allemande
c'est pourquoi la seconde lancée hier
aux pays arabes par le président prend
beaucoup d'importance à la tribune du
stade olympique
monsieur henman avait dit les
responsables sont aussi ceux qui
encouragent de tels actes les pays
arabes est avisé ce matin vous savez que
ceux ci protestent contre la phrase de
monsieur parent dit que monsieur brandt
en ternes indirects et par la voix de
son porte parole a fait savoir que le
président de la république avait
peut-être été dépassé par l'importance
des mots prononcés en tout cas si brandt
ne prononce pas cette fois de cette
façon il laisse bien entendre en tout
cas aussi monsieur willy brandt est bien
obligé d'admettre maintenant que le
principe des bonnes relations tous
azimuts maintenu contre vents et marées
par l'allemagne fédérale est
sérieusement battu en brèche au niveau
de l' enquête ce ministre de l'intérieur
du land de bavière vient de confirmer un
point important il a reconnu que les
premiers coups de feu à l'aéroport ont
été tirées par les policiers sur les
deux fedayin qui affectait l'avion qui
devait les importer au caire nous avons
tiré car nous avons
c'est que les autres fedayin à
l'intérieur des deux hélicoptères avec
les otages prendrait peur et se rendrait
aux villages olympiques les athlètes
reprenne tant bien que mal le sommet du
stade
les tunisiens des marocains les
égyptiens kit munich ainsi que quinze
norvégien et si hollandais chacun c'est
ici qu'il faut finir ces jeux qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'à dimanche
soir
on va encore distribuer des médailles
pour les prix mais dans les coeurs
la véritable cérémonie de clôture s'est
déroulée hier matin au stade olympique
d'ici munich avoue paris faut pourtant
revenir à l'aspect sportif de ces jeux
olympiques les françaises jouent le
désert ont tous tenu hier une médaille
d'argent en esprit michel drucker
oui on peut dire qu'une fois encore ce
sont les escrimeurs français qui auront
donné meilleur résultat à la france a
porté le meilleur résultat la france
vous souvenez que avec syco c'était
l'équipe de france de fleuret qui avait
remporté le titre par équipes
et puis la semaine dernière à munich il
y avait les escrimeurs français avait
obtenu deux médailles de bronze une au
fleuret par équipes et une au fleuret
individuel avec christian noël hier
c'est la consécration avec jacques la
galerie un garçon que le grand public ne
connaissait pas et qui n'est n'avait pas
encore remporté un titre de champion de
france je propose de voir comment s'est
passé hier à munich dans un climat un
peu différent celui derniers jours vous
le savez pourquoi
la cérémonie de remise des médailles
pour le l'épée individuelle
dr chabane ivg hongrie
romero jacques ladegaillerie frankreich
cette médaille de bronze dieuze kutxa
hongrie
vous verrez ce soir contre notre résumé
de 21h30 la première chaîne
quelques assauts de la galerie et sur
lequel il faut peut-être revenir car
encore mais c'est mal la personnalité du
français depuis hier il a 28 ans il
exerce la profession de professeur
d'éducation physique à la voûte le pays
des phares cambérabéro et rugbyman il
est marié il est père d'un petit garçon
de cinq ans il n'a jamais été champion
de france julie guillemet en soixante
dix il avait terminé 4e échapper à la
demande d'ankara
il ya eu également hier soir un
spectacle impressionnant il s'agissait
des épreuves d'haltérophilie dans la
catégorie super lourd et lent navy celui
qu'on appelle l'homme le plus fort du
monde alexeyev en effet cette finale des
super lourds et lycées quelques
mastodontes impressionnant et on
attendait beaucoup du duel entre
vaciller alexeïev le grand favori le
colosse soviétique et l'allemande de
l'ouest rudolph manque qui le talonnait
à quelques kilos près depuis quelques
mois je vous propose de voir alexeyev
entrait en action il n'a pas eu de
véritable duel quart monde n'a pas fait
de poids si j'ose dire mais qu'il pèse
130 kg devant ce géant soviétique qui va
réussir devant vous 230 kg 3e mouvement
c'est-à-dire à l'épaulé jeté
regardez c'est quelque chose 1 m 87 152
kg trois repas par jour quatre poules et
un rôti pour le petit déjeuner c'est un
colosse
il était déjà nettement en tête avec
seief après le deuxième mouvement il
avait 15 kg d'avant sur auzolle film
angle allemands de l'ouest qui a voté
briand est ici sous vos yeux
il va réussir à l'épaulé jeté vous savez
qu'il ya trois mouvements
l'haltérophilie le développer l'arraché
et l'épaulé-jeté on totalise les trois
ce qui donne au total olympique
alexeïev réussi 6 230 kg à l'épaulé-jeté
c'est vraiment l'homme le plus fort du
monde
il succède à pascal jabotinsky champion
olympique à mexico manque d'âme une
deuxième loin mais c'est relatif
d'affaires totalisé tout de même s'ils
sont vite il autres en mouvement alors
qu'à l'excellent hier a réussi 640 kg
nullement il approche pour encore
mondiale de 5 qui félicité par
entraîneur soviétique est impressionnant
monsieur l'extérieur aujourd'hui on suit
particulièrement les performances de
deux athlètes français d'une part guy
drut dans le 110 m haies cet après midi
en ce moment même d'ailleurs régis ovion
de champion du monde 71 qui est en train
de participer à la course sur la route
olympique
au dernier pointage lyon ne faisait pas
partie du groupe de tête
nous sommes à deux tours de l'arrivée
l'épreuve comporte 182 km et à 10 à 8
tours d'un circuit de 22 km au violon
n'était pas avec les favoris qui
s'appelait martens derrière toc tout à
l'heure mais la course n'est pas
terminée quand à drut et bien il sera en
piste vers 15h cet après midi il
rapporte à faire trois américains mildon
hill downpour milburn est le grand
favori après il est difficile de faire
un pronostic pour les deux autres
marches du podium et puis aussi une
finale du 400 m qui s'annonce
fantastique avec les trois américains
matthews colette et smit
mais toute l'allemagne aura les yeux
fixés sur karl freund son jeune prodige
qui a réalisé 44 secondes 7/10 huth qui
aura bien du mal à suivre le rythme de
matthew booth vers 17h30 cette fille là
voilà pour l'actualité sportive en ce
qui concerne le munich en revanche nous
reviendrons à l'acuité du football non à
la fin de ce genre d'ici quelques
minutes
l'actualité politique française allait
marquer aujourd'hui joue surtout vous le
savez par la visite officielle de
monsieur messmer en alsace est en effet
son son premier voyage officiel depuis
son arrivée à l'hôtel matignon
une visite qui doit le conduire de
strasbourg à mulhouse et colmar et qui
doit durer deux jours
compte rendu de cette première matinée
avec ge a quitté son premier voyage
officiel en province depuis qu'il est
premier ministre monsieur messmer a donc
choisi l'alsace pour les dimensions
c'est la plus petite région française
mais elle compte près d'un million et
demi d'habitants dont vingt-cinq mille
franchissent chaque jour le rhin pour
aller travailler en allemagne et en
suisse accompagné de trois ministres
jean charbonnel ministre du
développement industriel et scientifique
yvon bourges ministre du commerce et de
l'artisanat et andré board ministre des
anciens combattants will smith une super
serré la main une sucrine le maire de
strasbourg
monsieur messmer a d'abord participé aux
cérémonies traditionnel dépôt de gerbe
au monument aux morts et aux monuments
le play voici le moment le monde
oui monsieur l'espère prendra le
traditionnel bonne foule pour un premier
ministre et ensuite à la préfecture le
premier ministre a reçu des
personnalités de la région
le président de la chambre des métiers
les parlementaires les 13 députés
d'alsace sont aussi des airs des anciens
combattants des représentants des cultes
première prise de contact avec des
responsables
avant la réunion de la coc d'air cet
après midi réunion à laquelle
n'assistera pas la cgt en fin de matinée
le premier ministre a inauguré la foire
européenne de strasbourg 3000 exposants
34 nations représentées monsieur pierre
film là a déclaré dans son discours
d'accueil ne manquons jamais de rappeler
que strasbourg signifie étymologiquement
ville des routes
hélas nous ne méritons plus ce nom au
temps des autoroutes dans sa réponse
monsieur metzner a notamment abordé le
problème des travailleurs immigrés
les travailleurs frontaliers la mobilité
de la main-d'oeuvre dont tout le monde
parle ici en alsace comme d'ailleurs en
lorraine la mobilité de la main d'oeuvre
se traduit en ce moment par de grandes
migrations journalière à sens unique à
notre détriment
et ces migrations manifeste
l'insuffisante correspondance des
niveaux économiques de chaque côté du
fleuve se sont jeunes répètent des
situations qui sont connus dans d'autres
régions frontières que nous connaissons
lorraine que connaissent les francs
comtois que connaissent aussi les
habitants du pays john l mais peut-être
ces échanges journaliers ces
allers-retours sont ils plus sensibles
ici en alsace qu'ailleurs sans
contrarier cette fluidité qui est la
conséquence est disons le la conséquence
heureuse de la libre circulation des
hommes dans l'europe du marché commun il
faut rétablir progressivement un
meilleur équilibre économique entre les
deux rives du rhin
on ne peut tirer tout le bénéfice d'une
position centrale que par de bonnes
liaisons
vous l'avez rappelé et tous les
alsaciens le savent bien
l'alsace doit tête en communication
facile avec les régions voisines de
france comme avec les régions voisines
étrangères afin d'être ce lieu de
passage et de rencontre privilégié entre
la france et ses voisins mais en même
temps elle doit renforcer ses liaisons
avec paris et avec les autres régions de
la france d'abord ces régions voisines
pour le reste en france on continue de
commenter le plan social présenté hier
après-midi par monsieur messmer est un
monsieur de guerre fort je vous rappelle
que ce plan social concerne
particulièrement les personnes âgées les
familles à l'avenir la retraite sera
calculée sur les 10 meilleures années
d'activité professionnelle et non sur
les dix dernières ce qui est important
le minimum de vie et est garanti est
augmenté de 24 % il passe à 4500 francs
par an et par ailleurs les abattements
de zone sur les allocations familiales
seront supprimés à partir du 1er janvier
enfin une mesure pour les veuves qui
pourront obtenir la pension de
reversions à partir de 55 ans au lieu de
en contrepartie il y à une hausse
qualifiée de modérée sur la vignette
automobile sans doute 5 francs
d'augmentation jusqu'à quatre chevaux et
2 50 francs ou même cette hausse de 2 à
16 chevaux l'augmentation interviendrait
pour la vigne est mise en vente à la fin
73 bien sûr beaucoup de réactions à cet
ensemble de mesures je pense qu'il est
bon de vous fixer à ce sujet un rendez
vous pour ce soir avec l'actualité en
question un rendez vous comme à
l'habitude à 20h30 etienne mougeotte
recevra monsieur edgar faure le ministre
chargé des affaires sociales il répondra
aux questions de quatre journalistes
il ya d'ailleurs deux autres rendez vous
sociaux pour cet après midi d'abord la
déclaration de monsieur georges séguy
qui marquera sans doute la rentrée pour
la cgt et puis une délégation du cnpf
conduite par monsieur paul eu plein qui
doit être reçu par monsieur edgar faure
dans les milieux financiers on a suivi
avec intérêt bien sur le plan social
présenté hier commentaires à la bourse
de paris
gérard vidal hanche
jean-michel des jeunes je crois qu'il
faut distinguer les mesures sociales et
mesures immédiates
l'arrière-plan qui est en quelque sorte
l'avenir est également le financement de
ces mesures sociales en ce qui concerne
les mesures immédiates
la réaction est favorable je crois que
les général peut-être certains syndicats
ne sont pas là ils ne sont ils pas
entièrement satisfait disons qu'elle
concerne la france cacher la france
déshérités une france quand même de
misère donc je crois que de ce côté là
l'accueil favorable en ce qui concerne
alors disons l'avenir la relance de la
participation certains milieux
financiers s'inquiètent encore que cette
relance ne se produira que qu'après les
élections donc c'est encore assez flou
mais on monsieur edgar faure a parlé
d'une économie de participation et ceci
rappelle pour certains de mauvais
souvenirs
c'était l'époque de monsieur wallon et
monsieur wallon avait fait trembler la
bourse de paris
mais encore une fois il ya des éléments
très positifs notamment ses diffusions
de des actions de l'actionnariat est
évidemment un élément favorable pour le
marché financier
de même la volonté de développer
l'intéressement et de l'orienter plus
précisément vers les formules
d'actionnariat que vers les formules de
comptes bloqués simplement de l'argent
qui est déposée qui est rémunéré au sein
des entreprises
en ce qui concerne le financement pas de
problème dans l'immédiat
jusqu'aux élections mais on se demande
si après les élections il y aura tout de
même pas des charges supplémentaires
pour les entreprises
quoi qu'il en soit aujourd'hui la bourse
de paris est assez bien orienté surtout
sur les pétro nous en parlait tout à
l'heure une découverte encore nouvelle
encore une nouvelle découverte en mer
d'une heure qui concerne le gisement
d'ekofisk il y a à la fois des intérêts
français belge norvégien américain vous
voyez c'est un peu l'europe du pétrole
qui se trouve mise en évidence par ses
découvertes en mer du nord où
jean-michel des jeunes un conflit social
est en cours depuis la fin du mois
d'août il s'agit de lusine barreau clem
qui se trouve dans la banlieue de rouen
est depuis lundi il est occupé par des
ouvriers en grève le conflit qui oppose
les ouvriers à la direction de lézinnes
barreau clama grand quévilly dans la
banlieue de rouen n'est pas résolu y
asseoir une entrevue entre les
représentants des ouvriers la direction
s'est poursuivie assez tard à la cité
administrative devront discussions qui
se déroulaient en présence de
représentants de l'inspection du travail
ce n'est qu'à 22 heures en effet
qu'elles ont été terminés au cours des
négociations la direction devait faire
des propositions sur les salaires et le
13e mois
ce matin en assemblée générale les
grévistes les juges est insuffisante et
refusé de reprendre le travail
en effet aucune solution n'avait été
apportée à leurs conditions de travail
demain le comité d'hygiène doit examiner
les locaux poursuite donc de la grève
chez parrot clame le syndicat ont
demandé à la direction
une nouvelle entrevue sur la scène
internationale deux informations à
propos du vietnam d'abord en avions
soviétiques étaient retenus sur
l'aéroport de vienne siad l'appareil est
entouré par des soldats là haussier en
croit sa joie à savoir pardon qu'il
s'agit d'un avion qui transportait des
armes vers hanoï pour tenter de rompre
le blocus américain du nord vietnam
et puis les communistes ont attaqué ce
matin la ville de thiennes floch qui se
trouve à 60 km au sud de danang pour la
première fois d'ailleurs des chars ont
été utilisés ont été utilisés dans ce
secteur en argentine le directeur de la
société philips qui avait été enlevé
mardi vous savez par un commando
révolutionnaire a été libéré hier soir
les ravisseurs font partie de cette même
organisation qui avait enlevé en avril
dernier le directeur général de la fiac
monsieur salustro cette fois ci l'avait
demandé ils avaient demandé une rançon
d'un demi million de dollars
il est probable qu'ils aient obtenu
satisfaction
retour à l'actualité sportive avec la
journée de championnat de football il ya
un hier et hier soir et d'abord au parc
des princes hier soir le paris football
club recevait l'olympique de marseille
michel où il faut dire que les trois
leaders ont gagné c'est à dire marseille
ni à paris nous verrons dans un instant
nice qui recevait mais c'est qui a eu la
main lourde vous l'avais dit au début de
ce journal et puis angers qui a gagné à
bordeaux c'est une bonne performance
pour les angevins qui sont toujours bien
placé donc dans ce championnat
professionnel je vous propose de voir
tout de suite comme l'olympique de
marseille a battu le paris football club
hier soir dans le nouveau parc des
princes c'est michel devrait glisser à
cette rencontre et qui va sans doute
nous dire que l'olympique de marseille
attire toujours la grande foule
les joueurs de l'olympique de marseille
tout en blanc retrouver le parc des
princes trois mois exactement après leur
finale de coupe de france gagné devant
bastia plus de trente mille personnes
étaient venues encourager le paris fc
qui avait perdu ses trois derniers
matches de championnat les parisiens
très entreprenant vont prendre avantage
dès la 12e minute sur cette action de
cela se regarder le ballon est renvoyé
par l'un des montants tir de prost
carnus repousse mais guignedoux bien
placé marque le premier but
mais cinq minutes avant le repos sur
cette contre attaque amorcée par leclerc
les marseillais vont égaliser par
bernard bosquier contrôle de la poitrine
et tire du gauche malgré la charge de
chats puise un à un les marseillais
étaient très heureux mais au même moment
ils perdaient jacky novy qui se
faisaient une entorse
sa participation au match de coupe
d'europe est incertaine en seconde
période sous la conduite d'un skoblar en
super forme
les marseillais vont faire la différence
il y aura aussi une faute un peu sévère
sanctionné par l'arbitré sur cette
action accrochage entre le gardien icher
et buick qui avait remplacé nos vies
coup franc pour marseille
à la 70e minute deux tiers de leclerc
qui avait remplacé franceschetti reprise
de la tête de bonnet malgré son courage
et sa détermination la formation
entraînée par louis lions ne pourra
refaire son retard et c'est encore
leclerc qui va offrir à skoblar à dix
minutes de la fin de la rencontre
le troisième et dernier but marseillais
une reprise superbe quatrième défaite
pour les parisiens les choses deviennent
sérieuses au paris fc où l'on parle de
la venue d'un nouveau joueur
tout va bien donc un olympique de
marseille en revanche a vu celui superbe
de skoblar la pile de marseille qui rend
compte
pour rappel mercredi prochain à lyon le
13 la juventus de turin pour le compte
du premier tour de la coupe d'europe des
clubs champions
quant au paris football club michel
drainville a dit il va chercher à se
renforcer on parle beaucoup de
spiegeleer le meilleur joueur de
football d'israël on parle aussi
beaucoup toujours de keita et de 13
heures nous allons maintenant avec jean
jacques riou var ce qui s'est passé hier
au stade du ray à nice où la tacc
mitrailleuses de nice a facilement battu
l'équipe de metz qui n'est pourtant pas
la première venue
nice en direct il aura fallu une
vingtaine de minutes aux niçois que vous
allez découvrir en maillot blanc qu'une
auto noir à gauche sur votre écran au
prendre la mesure des messins dès lors
il n'eut qu'une équipe sur le terrain
à la 27e minute tu que réalise un une
deux avec loubet et centre laulan des
ventes d'ed de la tête loge le ballon
dans la lucarne des buts gardés par
barre 1-0 les messins sont submergés
toute l'équipe joue en défense seul sort
même bien faible hier soir en reste en
attaque
un 33ème minute le ballon voyage de pied
ni soir mme kieny soir est révélée dans
nos très bonnes conditions va être servi
dans l'autre il va voir leur son pied
droit bloqué par bollier penalty dire à
monsieur distance
penalty van dyck ne laisse aucune chance
à l'infortuné bart 2 0 est en superforme
multiplient les raids sur l'ailé droite
et à tous les coups il mystifie vaste
hall à la 42e minute il donne un très
bon ben alors à rêver lit et c'est le
troisième mi-temps 3-0 pour nice
même scénario à la reprise les buts
messins bombardier à la 47e minute à la
suite d'une attaque niçoise un tir de
van dyck est repoussé par bart revelli
reprend boullier va repousser une
nouvelle fois mais il a remonté en
attaque marque kabze vous le numéro 12
mai samba sy qui remplaçait rastoll et
c'est de secouer son attaque mais rien
ne passe à la 76e minute direction de
cervelli qui va devancer bart et marqué
son deuxième but 5 0 coup de grâce à la
86e minute
hugues encore lui déborde dans la
camerini j'ai dégagé de la tête un
ballon que j'ouvre de volée l'ange dans
les buts de bars 6 0 ce sera le score
final l'addition aurait pu être plus
lourd plus lourd et bien si vous habitez
la côte maternelle j'ai beaucoup de
chance car vous avez maintenant de très
bonnes équipes olympique de marseille
et puis l'olympique gymnaste club de
nice nous allons maintenant voir ce qui
s'est passé hier à nantes où il y avait
un derby breton entre nantes et rennes
depuis nantes michel bart 23 mille
spectateurs hier soir au stade marcel
saupin parmi eux quelques-uns étaient
venus de très loin
match très rapidement menés dès le début
chacune des deux équipes opérant par
contre attaque première occasion
rennaise à la 12e minute kerusore qui
rentrent de très peu à côté bertrand
demanes ne semblait battu
la réplique dans taz est immédiate mais
pas plus fructueuse ce n'est que partie
remise puisqu'à la 29e minute sur un
service de marcos rampillon déclenche un
tir très violent qui naissaient aucune
chance à daniel bernard à zéro donc pour
nantes ce sera le score à la mise
le match baissait ensuite d'intensité
nantes contrôler la situation et se
créaient deux belles occasions surtout
en
fin de match mais rennes a eu de très
bonnes réactions comme celle de fanta
mady keita ici qui oblige bertrand
demanes spectaculaire à 1 0 score final
c'est le reflet de la faible différence
il y avait hier soir entre les deux
équipes
merci michel barnes l'on voit maintenant
le l'ensemble des résultats sur notre
panneau vous voyez donc il est trop vite
qui les trois victoires sur le terrain
de l'adversaire marseille à paris angers
à bordeaux saint-etienne à sedan et dans
l'ensemble les scores sont nets
il faut noter l'excellent résultat
obtenu par le red star a strasbourg il
n'est pas facile de ramener un point du
stade de la meinau et excellents
résultats aussi pour bastien l'équipe de
bastia fort bien joué elle a battu
sochaux et il faut dire que les
bastilles été privés de calmette odoul
et pantelic ce qui est une bonne chose
avec bastia rencontre l'atlético de
madrid le 14 à ajaccio en coupe des
vainqueurs de coupe ce match sur un
tailleur télévisée en direct je rappelle
sur la première chaîne à 20h30
le classement 1er nice om même et angers
9 points 4e set et i am et nîmes nîmes a
battu ajaccio hier 7e les équipes de
l'ouest rennes et nantes ensemble avec 6
points en fin de classement ajaccio
ferme la marche avec le stade de reims
canton le paris football club mais il
est 18e avec deux points voilà pour la
qualité
merci michel vous souvenez sans doute
que nous avions consacré le mois dernier
un hebdo midi spécial au dauphin avec
roger pic nous avions fait plus que
connaissance avec cet animal
extraordinaire qui reste l'un des grands
amis de l'homme il arrive que l'homme
sache l'en remercie c'est ce qui vient
de se passer à antibes avec la la
mésaventure heureusement terminée de
splatch le dauphin
les heures d'inquiétude ne sont
maintenant qu'un mauvais souvenir au
marineland de la brague hillion les
faits quelques jours le dauphin vedette
de marineland tombé malade splatch tel
est son nom souffrait d'une assez graves
complications pulmonaires aussitôt tout
était mis en oeuvre pour sauver l'animal
et pour la première fois on avait essayé
l'oxygène doublé de tous les
antibiotiques nécessaire placé à
l'intérieur de sa nourriture
c'était pour les dresseurs et pour le
directeur de marineland une expérience à
tenter une opération survie
monsieur de la poype nous explique
aujourd'hui qu'elle fut le traitement de
son malade
dans le cas de splash après le
traitement de bases normales sont et à
continuer à empirer et malgré les
prélèvements qui a été fait qui ont été
faits des prélèvements de gorge des
vents et de salive
nous sommes rendus compte qu'il y avait
quelque chose de différent et que par
conséquent il fallait agir très vite
pour pouvoir le tirer d'affaires nos
soigneurs ont imaginé une chose qui
n'avait jamais été employé jusqu'à
présent d'employés l'oxygène de façon à
augmenter son auto de globules rouges et
lui faciliter sa respiration et de fait
ce traitement s'est avéré très valable
parce que dans les quelques heures qui
suivaient la respiration de l'animal
s'est calmé et petit à petit il a pu
assimiler d'un meilleures conditions
tous les antibiotiques nous lui donnions
donc souvent comparé les dauphins l'être
humain au point de vue intelligence bien
sur escaut point de vue traitement on
peut aussi le comparer à l'être moins
mais oui il ya beaucoup nous avons fait
le marineland a une double vocation
d'abord faire connaître les animaux au
public qui vient nous visiter et ensuite
les étudier sur le plan de la biologie
ou de la physiologie de ces animaux nous
sommes arrivés quand même à certains
résultats compte tenu des animaux que
nous avons récupérés en mer qui nous ont
été apportées par les gens par des
pêcheurs que nous avons capturé nous
même dans certaines conditions et nous
sommes rendu compte que beaucoup
d'affection des dauphins étaient
identiques à ceux de l'homme par contre
certaines de ces affections ne sont pas
encore connues et notamment nous avons
découvert il ya à peu près six mois de
ça que certains dauphin de la
méditerranée avaient avec eux dans leur
corps
un germe staphylocoques qui n'existait
pas jusqu'à présent et qui n'était pas
répertoriée sur les germes différents et
virus que vous trouvez généralement chez
l'être humain splatch comme tous les
membres de sa famille nous ont plu pour
l'homme des animaux
on ne peut s'empêcher de l'est
personnifié et l'on avait même
l'impression en regardant ce dauphin
qu'il se savait malade mais tout comme
chez l'homme le courage doit exister
chez le dauphin le courage et l'espoir
le splash en l'espace de deux jours
ensuite à récupérer totalement
et maintenant de le retrouver dans son
bassin à l'heure actuelle alors que nous
allions donner comme condamné il y a
trois quatre jours nous le retrouvons je
compterai grande forme puisqu'il s'est
trouvé une compagne qui a chipé à l'un
de ses amis
oui je crois que là alors là comme celle
sommes costauds du marineland
il n'a pas eu de pitié pour son petit
camarade et maintenant ils sont tous les
deux alors que l'autre est en train de
rester tranquillement son coin mais
peut-être un petit peu tristement tout
le monde à marineland partage la joie de
ce plaquage qui vous salue bien bas qui
vous remercie de vos bons voeux et qui
se demande encore s'il n'est pas le plus
beau conquérant de l'homme faute d'en
être la plus belle conquête
mésaventure loyers qui se termine bien
secteur peut-être plus austère la bourse
les cotations gérard vidal hanche et
bien jean-michel non aujourd'hui les
boursiers sont très joyeux car je vous
le disais encore une découverte de
pétrole en mer du nord
on apprend des noms nouveaux et je crois
que les étudiants sont obligés de les
retenir les noms des prochains gisements
de pétrole qu'ils ne reverront peut-être
pas quand même les gisements fabuleux du
moyen orient mais tout de même qui
compteront dans l'approvisionnement de
l'europe
eh bien le gisement question est un
gisement à 12 kilomètres au sud des
côtes fisc et c'est un des gisements qui
a été découvert par un groupe américain
philip petroleum 40% dans ce gisement
petrochina la société belge 30% et il
put petro nord 20% repreneur est un
consortium européen qui réunit à la fois
des norvégiens des français avec la
française des pétroles et health ainsi
que les pétroles d'aquitaine ainsi que
d'autres petites petites compagnies
françaises puis à les italiens à jeep
avec 13% et bien les autres noms le
gisement
je vous en ai déjà parlé c'est brain pc
en dehors des grossistes et fortis et
frigg et voici le court précisément de
la française des pétroles qui a monté
aujourd'hui les gars crochet le cours de
230 reprise des affaires de matériel
téléphonique avait été secoué comme lmt
qui regagne 40 francs aujourd'hui
carrefour la grande vedette 3760 donc 76
points de mieux
c'est un cours record aujourd'hui
toujours pour rester dans le pétrole la
compagnie française des pétroles annonce
ses résultats semestriels qui sont en
baisse de 8%
cette baisse s'explique tout simplement
par le fait que les enlèvements de
pétrole de l'irak ont diminué après la
nationalisation de l'iraq petroleum la
société et s'empresse de dire que les
ventes du troisième trimestre sont en
net redressement donc accident de
parcours
il ne faut pas prêter trop d'attention à
ce recul de 8%
carrefour donc 3760 on a baissé tout de
même en séance 3752
présent à signaler enfin que les
stations de service des sceaux vont
changer de nom elles s'appelleront exxon
en effet la société américaine ascendant
au new jersey dont dépend la société
française et son stand en france et bien
change de nom et s'appelle ex magasin
peu de fluctuation avec une même unosel
de prénatal qui approche de cours de 300
à 2 198 une baisse toutefois tout de
même d'ocré - qui perd 5 6 francs 50
vous savez qu'il y à une grande bataille
en italie au sujet du procédé de
télévision en couleurs est ce que ce
sera le procès des français le secam où
le procès des allemands en pal
le gouvernement américain a été
l'italien pardon examiner la question
hier aucune décision n'a encore été
prise mais il ya une forte opposition à
la fois des milieux industriels et des
milieux politiques pour le procès des
français quoi qu'il en soit la lutte est
encore ouverte décision seulement dans
quelques mois usineurs assez ferme
on s'attend à une reprise des valeurs
sidérurgiques car la conjoncture
c'est à dire les perspectives dans la
sidérurgie son meilleur depuis quelques
mois le marché de l'or est très calme
aujourd'hui ce sont pratiquement les
mêmes cours verront le lingot à 10620
cinq fois mieux seulement tandis que le
napoléon est en baisse 10 centimes 75 10
ajoute qu'il y ait un cours record sur
la rampe il est à 91 100 91 70 avoue
jean-michel des jeunes merci gérard la
sainte du jour s'entraîne aujourd'hui on
fête également les régimes et les réjane
sainte reine est vénéré dans la côte
d'or et sa biographie indique que tout
comme sainte marine à elle avait refusé
de se donner un gouverneur ainsi se
termine cette édition de télé me dis
merci de nous avoir prêté attention je
vous retrouve à 19h45